monsieur gérald darmanin monsieur madame
la présidente monsieur le premier
ministre ma question s'adresse à vous
l'europe depuis des mois tant de se
mobiliser contre l'afflux massif des
migrants si l'on peut regretter
amèrement la position de la france qui
est derrière françois hollande a suivi
aveuglément la position de mme merkel on
ne peut qu assumer aujourd'hui pour
l'état les conséquences les conséquences
d'une telle politique
les conséquences de ce premier ministre
une des conséquences
aujourd'hui nous avons appris dans la
presse locale la voix du nord que la
sncf avec stupéfaction devant le grand
nombre de migrants dans les trains
permettait de ne pas contrôler les
migrants ou pire de les laisser voyager
à 0
de préférence en première classe en
seconde à ce monsieur monsieur le
premier ministre
non seulement la sncf ne dément pas mais
en plus de ce premier ministre elle a
l'air d'accepter cette décision
ahurissante
comment accepter monsieur le premier
ministre que défend celle où des
étrangers en situation régulière paye
normalement le train alors que des
migrants ou des clandestins puissent
prendre les trains sans payer leur
ticket
comment accepter monsieur premier
ministre que le gouvernement qui
contrôle l'entreprise publique sncf ne
soient pas informés ou pire cautionne
cette politique de la part de ses
grandes entreprises publiques
cela revient ni plus ni moins de laissé
comme message allez à calais par le
train c'est gratuit alors monsieur le
premier ministre
étiez vous informer de cette politique
de la sncf
avez-vous cautionner ces politiques de
la sncf
et sinon allez vous aujourd'hui demandé
au président de la sncf de revenir sur
cette ahurissante instruction
la parole et de la parole est ton
premier ministre madame
madame la présidente monsieur le
monsieur le député darmanin d'abord misé
de l'intérieur pu vous répondre
également mais je vais large irma
réponse le ministère de l'intérieur je
vous le rappelle a mis en place et vous
le savez est renforcée un dispositif
dans tous les trains et les gares afin
de lutter contre les flux migratoires
utilisant les vecteurs ferroviaire
chaque jour dans un contexte très
difficile dans le contexte migratoires
que nous connaissons
c'est plus de 200 interpellations par
jour dans les trains et dans les gares
qui sont réalisés majoritairement dans
le sud
nous y reviendrons tout à l'heure et
dans la région nord pas de calais à
travers l'action de la brigade
spécialisée de la police de l'air et des
frontières
aucune instruction n'a été donnée à la
sncf de relâcher ce contrôle bien au
contraire
tout voyageur doit être muni d'un titre
de transport et tout le monde est soumis
à la même procédure de contrôle à bord
des trains migrants inclut bien
évidemment donc cette information n'a
pas de sens et ne croyez pas tout ce qui
se dit monsieur darmanin dans la presse
deuxièmement il avait prononcé au début
de votre intervention
une phrase qui est assez étrange
d'ailleurs
à propos de ce qui serait le suivisme du
gouvernement français à l'égard de
l'allemagne
d'abord mettons les choses au clair et
harlem désir le rappelait tout à l'heure
l'europe sur tous les sujets puisque
nous parlons d'europe aujourd'hui madame
la présidente sur l'euro ou sur le
dossier des migrants doit avancer doit
avancer grâce à l'engagement du couple
franco allemand
grâce à l'engagement de la france et de
l'allemagne et ce sont les mêmes dans
vos rangs y compris vous monsieur
darmanin qui vous donnait des leçons sur
le plan économique sur ce que fait
l'allemagne en nous expliquant qu'il
faudrait suivre l'allemagne et qui nous
accuserait maintenant sur les questions
migratoires en nous trompant par
ailleurs deux jeunes séquelles suivisme
à l'égard de madame merkel que je chasse
monsieur darmanin madame merkel
et comme vous membres du même parti
européen le ppe alors mettez vous
d'accord avec le ppe et avec madame
merkel avant de mettre en cause je ne
sais quel gouvernement ici en france sur
les questions de migrants sur la crise
des réfugiés
la force de la france ça a été sa
cohérence et sa constance depuis un an
grâce notamment au travail qui a été
mené par le ministre de l'intérieur et
sur ce sujet là vous remarquez quand les
faits même si nous comprenons ce qui
peut se passer en allemagne
nous avons adopté d'autres choix une
autre politique
un autre message qui est celui
aujourd'hui de la france et nous l'avons
déjà dit très clairement et je
l'occasion de vous le dire ici aussi
nettement
nous pensons que l'europe et donc la
france ne peuvent pas accueillir tous
les réfugiés aujourd'hui qui fuient la
guerre en syrie pour des raisons
évidentes et c'est pour cela que nous
avons un plan européen qui est celui qui
a pas été adopté par un ou deux pays qui
est celui suivi par l'ensemble des pays
européens sauf les deux ou trois qui se
sont opposés qui est la mise en place
des centres d'accueil le renforcement de
nos frontières avec des gardes-frontière
l'aide et nous l'avons constaté encore
ces derniers jours en jordanie au pays
les plus concernés la jordanie la
turquie et le liban
le soutien bien sûr à la grèce et à
l'italie parce que vous courrez derrière
l'extrême droite monsieur darmanin
parce que vous couriez derrière le front
national parce que vous courrez derrière
madame le pen parce que avec d'autres
vous courrez derrière on peut pas en
même temps
monsieur darmanin accusé à juste titre
madame le pen de ne pas avoir été à la
hauteur et le mot est faible
d'avoir interpellé comme vous le savez
de quelle manière le président de la
république et enfourcher ici à
l'assemblée nationale ou sur le terrain
dans le nord pas de calais les mêmes
thèmes qui sont ceux de l'extrême droite
qui consiste en permanence à m le
réfugié l'immigré en profondeur au coeur
du débat politique alors monsieur
darmanin oui le débat puisqu'il s'agit
bien de cela nous l'avons bien compris
des régionales
plus que jamais c'est une certaine
conception de la république des valeurs
et la manière de faire de la politique
notamment quand on gouverne et ceux qui
courent derrière l'extrême droite
merci le premier mouvement c'est le
premier ministre à paroles et